بداية، أنا ممتن جدًا
لحضور صاحب السمو الملكي،
لقد كان شرفًا لي أن أكون هنا على الرغم من أنني
لا أعتبر نفسي ضيفًا، فأنا
جزء من هذا البلد وجزء من العائلة
وأعتزم التنافس مع  السعوديون والرجال
والنساء على حد سواء الذين حضروا
كأس العالم
وجلبوا الفرح والعاطفة
وأظهروا تلك الفرحة والعاطفة والحب
لهذا البلد وشعبه،
لذا فإن
مكاني وما أنا هنا من أجله هو ذلك
وتلك على وجه التحديد الأشياء الأخرى
هي التفاصيل
تتغير بالطبع نعم إلى
الأبد نعم ولكن كما تعلم نحن
أشخاص مرتاحون أه نحن نأخذ الأمور في نطاق مختلف
نحن نركز على الصورة الأكبر
نعم الفروق الدقيقة في اليوم
وغدًا وبعد غد حاسمة ولكننا
نتعامل معها تكتيكيًا
نحن في المملكة العربية السعودية لدينا رؤية
تسمى 2030. هذا هو محركنا الرئيسي،
كل شيء
يدور حوله ويدور حوله، لذلك
مهما كان الناس يسألون أحيانًا عما
ينوون فعله هنا وهناك،
كل ما أحتاج إلى إخبارهم به هو
الرجوع وقراءة ما  لقد قمنا بتجميعها
في تلك الرؤية
وستجد كل الإجابات الخاصة بك